hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
cancel culture continues to be a hot
topic on social media
with everyone from congressional
lawmakers to actress bella thorne
sharing their opinion on it
fox news podcast host and publisher of
the federalist ben dominic breaks down
the controversial trend
and why he says it's not going anywhere
anytime
soon and hollywood loves a good comeback
story
the 93rd academy awards kick off sunday
after a two-month postponement
and a brutal year for the film business
with the coronavirus pandemic
halting productions forcing movie
theaters to close
and studios to shelve big ticket
blockbusters waiting for audiences to
return to the cinema
fox business correspondent susan lee
discusses the health crisis's impact on
awards season
and what the industry may look like in a
post-pandemic world
plus commentary from former white house
speech writer mark thiessen
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm abby hornacek this is tucker carlson
and i'm jessica tarlov this is the fox
news rundown
friday april 23rd 2021
i'm lisa brady we hear the words woke
race cancelled and boycott a lot lately
so is this tension here to stay i think
that the culture war
is not going to leave us alone anymore
it's going to be a dominant
factor that takes over our entire
conversations
for the foreseeable future i'm chris
foster
people are starting to go back to the
movies but some changes to the movie
business brought about or sped up by the
coronavirus pandemic may stick around
there's a rethink right now especially
from the movie
business and the theatrical releases and
whether or not the theatrical window
is toast because you saw that this year
right with warner brothers
and hbo max releasing these blockbusters
simultaneously
on streaming and in the theaters please
speak with fox business correspondent
susan lee
and i'm mark thiessen i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
one debate leads to another on capitol
hill
for instance the house vote thursday to
make washington dc
the 51st state democrats say it's about
full representation for d.c residents
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
says
it's really about a much broader agenda
another ploy to consolidate power
so they can jam through socialist
policies like the green new deal
court packing and the funding of the
police this as dozens of house democrats
sent a letter urging the senate to scrap
its filibuster rule
which requires 60 votes to advance most
measures my constituents
do not care about arcane senate rules
and procedures
instead colorado congressman jason crowe
says they care about gun violence health
care and the climate crisis
suggesting republicans and rules are
standing in the way
but is the country really as divided as
the political debates
sound the fact is that most americans
actually have
similar views when it comes to the way
that they view their neighbors the way
that they engage
on issues of race and politics
ben dominic is publisher of the
federalist a fox news contributor
and host of the ben dominic podcast they
aren't as far apart
as the media might reflect in terms of
the way that they interact with these
issues and yet
the dominant big tech backed
media entities that exist out there
frequently
engage on these subjects in ways that
are designed to foment
division certainly i think that that's
true when it comes to
the issue of critical race theory its uh
injection
into our schools and our education
system
and our workplaces where you see you
know people who are
truly afraid of expressing themselves
in public on any number of different
news issues and
political issues for fear that they will
you know run up against a significant
human resources complaint or
have their own careers affected in a
negative fashion
by expressing views and that's something
that i think
we see taking on a newly weaponized
nature underneath a biden administration
that really does seek to put these
issues at the center of the conversation
repeatedly
when you look at the speech that he gave
the other night regarding
the george floyd verdict it was one that
was
essentially condemning america
overwhelmingly
as being a systemically racist nation
this is not the kind of thing that we've
heard from a president before
and it's very disturbing to me because
it
represents a real break with history
when it comes to not just
the way that presidents interact with
these divisive issues but also
to the way that the democratic party has
interacted with them
historically since anyone who doesn't
fit or follow
the chosen narrative though does seem to
risk getting cancelled or boycotted
um you know is is there a way
to turn a corner on this or is this just
going to continue
unless there's a change in
administration i think that the culture
war
is not going to leave us alone anymore
it's going to be a dominant
factor that takes over our entire
conversations
for the foreseeable future this is
unfortunate
it's not the kind of thing that we have
experienced historically in america
but it is i believe the reality that we
have to wrestle with
unfortunately uh there are increasing
demands
on normal american citizens to
take stands on issues that historically
had been
much more you know the realm of
politicians or public figures
instead i think people have to be ready
for the fact that the bumper sticker
they have on their car
the shows that they watch the
things that they bring up in water
cooler conversation
are going to be used against them or
could be used against them
by all manner of their fellow citizens
that's not something
historically in america that we've seen
it has much more in common
with the maoist cultural revolution in
china
but it is something that i think we have
to grapple with and wrestle with because
it is the new reality and it is endorsed
not just by these woke lefties who have
come out
of the ivy league system and now run our
hr departments
and more but also by so many
big american corporations who find that
to be the path of least resistance
is this something only republicans are
worried about though i mean and i'm not
trying to vilify
democrats and there are many democrats
who are just good people and want things
to be better for more people
i'm sure but it's it seems like when you
talk about kind of this new reality
is that something only republicans are
worried about and
the rest of the country that isn't
republican thinks it's just fine
it's actually not and here's why because
there's so many people who
fall into the category of what you might
consider
an old guard liberal if you look across
the media landscape i'm sure
people are familiar with hearing these
kinds of things from the likes of bill
maher
but they're also hearing it from a
number of people like
stephen pinker or andrew sullivan or
others who are in that category of
actually believing what the aclu was
saying back in the 1990s
instead now they're being put into a
position where
they can be canceled uh or or really
have their careers
diminished or struck down by an
increasingly woke
left and this is something that you saw
play out at the new york times as well
the reality is that these are people who
have very little tolerance for anyone
who breaks with them
on their woke ideology and for many of
these old guard liberals who came up
with you know the idea that
they were the ones in favor of free
speech that they were the ones who were
taking a stand against
puritanical conservatives they're the
ones who are
often you know at the at the tip of the
spear on this
and are frequently running into the
challenges
of what gen z is demanding of them
when it comes to all of these different
ideological tests
that's something that i think is going
to become an increasing
political divide between whether you
value free speech and free thought
or whether you are beholden to these
young woke interests that seek only to
dominate to destroy and to
eradicate people who have the audacity
to speak out in ways that conflicts with
their ideology
do you think democrats are
underestimating an
issue like ending the filibuster in the
senate or would enough people
care about that if it happens for it to
make a difference in the next election
cycle let's say
the filibuster always struck me as being
the thing that was likeliest to change
out of all of the extreme steps that the
biden administration might take up it
makes it
it's a lot more likely to me that the
filibuster goes away
than that for instance washington dc or
puerto rico becomes states
or that they are able to pack the
supreme court
but the filibuster is a in a senate uh
historical item
that fewer people have allegiances to
and obviously if it vanishes that means
that there's a number of things that
would
immediately be put in place in terms of
changes i will say that
i think that there is going to be a push
back against it from
members of the senate uh like joe
manchin uh who
can understand the negative consequences
of taking this kind of move
but whether they're able to succeed
within that conference
is really a close run thing and i think
that
if the filibuster ultimately does go
away
you will see a cascade of leftist
policies trying to be pushed through in
very short order
because democrats are concerned that
they are running into
a real headwind when it comes to the
upcoming midterms
well people can enjoy a deeper dive
into these kinds of issues and a whole
host of other things
on your new podcast congratulations on
your podcast
um what are you hoping that listeners
find with you i mean you have a
big range of guests in addition to a big
range of topics
well i hope that people can find the
conversations that they don't
necessarily get to experience on
cable news only because of the
restrictions of
of that format uh longer conversations
with really intelligent people from a
wide variety
of backgrounds we've had you know
best-selling authors and we've had
uh you know people who uh it changed the
world of sports like bill james we've
had
comedians like adam corolla and i think
that one of the things that i really
want to achieve with it
is to carve out a space where we can
have longer conversations that really do
dive deeply into a number of different
subjects that
are at the center of american discussion
and and deserve that kind of time and
investment
i notice you end your podcast with
something that's also on the federalist
website be lovers of freedom and anxious
for the fray
for anyone who doesn't know already
where is that from and why is it
important
so that's a comment that is from a
calvin coolidge speech
about bunker hill he said
that that the soldiers of bunker hill
were lovers of freedom
anxious for the fray who
who bowed in the dust before their lord
but hesitated not
to set their foot on the neck of their
king it's a bit of
rebellion and it's a reminder that our
heritage is one of rebellion
against the idea of kings and against
the idea
of uh the right to rule based on a
monarchical system that's something that
i think
in america we need to have as a value
that we push back against the idea
that the elite are allowed to rule the
people simply by virtue of their
position
in life and they've been hosting the 7
p.m hour
on fox news channel this week as well
how's that been
kind of a different animal it is a
different animal and honestly
uh it's been a challenge i i feel pretty
exhausted it drains you
the the my plan had been to start
serious and to get a little looser as
the week went on
but then we have the george floyd
verdict we have uh this
obviously you know tragic incident uh
with this
knife attack it's been a very serious
set of topics but i'll tell you uh being
able to delve into
a lot of different areas that i think
are serious and that the american people
need to understand
has been a real blessing and it's a it's
a great opportunity and i appreciate it
i hope people will check out the ben
dominic podcast
and um certainly the the public
discourse seems richer
with you in it so thank you very much
for coming on the run down we appreciate
it
a pleasure to be with you
[Music]
this is mark thiessen with your fox news
commentary coming up
the academy awards are on sunday like
with every other movie over the last 13
months very few people actually saw this
year's nominees in theaters because of
the coronavirus pandemic
promising young woman made 6.2 million
dollars in u.s ticket sales a huge bomb
any other year
it's every guy's worst nightmare getting
accused like that
can you guess what every woman's worst
nightmare is
but it's the highest grossing movie
among the eight up for best picture
it doesn't mean people didn't see those
movies they just saw them at home rented
or on a streaming service
overall at actual movie theaters in 2020
ticket sales were down 80 percent
would have been down even more except
for a strong january and february last
year before coronavirus shutdown started
those restrictions are being lifted now
fully in some place partially in others
ticket sales aren't expected to get back
to normal right away people are hoping
that maybe with more vaccines being
doled out
and the reopening of the economy that
maybe will get a blockbuster summer
season
susan lee is a fox business
correspondent we have some of the
blockbusters
already delayed till thanksgiving and
that includes top gun 2 maverick
but i say you've waited 35 years to
watch the sequel
what's another few months yeah i mean
some movies that were supposed to come
out
last year already kicked to like you
said thanksgiving or even some cases
like early next year that's right
uh yeah so um look so i've talked to
some movie industry
insider type people who say this is just
a blip people are always going to go to
the movies even with streaming like they
still go to ball games even though
they're
on tv for example right now right
i mean a big yeah i mean a big sign of
hope has been this godzilla versus kong
yes it did it did really good business
relative to how many people like you
said could even be in a theater even
though it was on hbo max at the exact
same time
yeah and going to going to the movies
and committing your times it's a
different thing than doing it on your
couch with your phone in your hand
that's right and you wonder how much
consumer habits are going to change and
hold after covet is done like will you
still want to go back to the theaters
with bubblegum on your feet or people
just chewing very loudly and kicking
your chair
i don't know there's a there's a rethink
right now especially from the
movie business and the theatrical
releases and whether or not that
theatrical window
is toast because you saw that this year
right with warner brothers
and hbo max releasing these blockbusters
simultaneously
on streaming and in the theaters now
hollywood was up in arms you had the
hollywood agents and stars
you they they said we didn't sign up for
this we expect to be on the big screen
first so they're going to
bring back at least warner brothers
we'll bring back some of that small
window
where it's on the screen first and then
it goes back onto the tv and the digital
properties
but you wonder how long that's going to
sustain for yeah i mean it used to be
months and months and months before back
in the day a movie would show up on
vhs tape or hbo or
yeah or blu-ray or whatever hbo whatever
we had then and now like you said it can
literally be the exact same day so
they're gonna have to do a rethink of
the relationship between movie companies
and theater companies maybe maybe
some more ticket money stays with the
theaters i don't know yeah well i would
say that there has been some
encouraging signs this week that maybe
maybe the big screens and going back to
the theaters is something that we'll do
again once kovitt is done you saw that
with did you see netflix's earnings
and their guidance they only got it for
a million
new paying subscribers this springtime
from march to june that is the lowest in
netflix's history i've never seen a
million
new subscriber ads and they're saying
that kovit there was a pull forward
effect so the people that wanted to sign
up for netflix
they already did last year in 2020 when
they were locked down and stuck at home
and
streaming on a lot of netflix but this
year
you know that might change maybe they
want to go out they don't want to be
stuck at home they've been doing this
for
15 months and when the economy reopens
they actually want to see people
experience things together so i think
there might be some hope
in those indications that things might
pick up once again
yeah i mean i guess you're right
probably everybody who has netflix has
netflix and also there's
there's some indication that people are
just starting to churn a little bit too
with all these
with all the different streaming
services like well i don't need four or
five at a time maybe if there's some hot
show on netflix i keep that for a month
and binge it and then i switch to
something else
is that what you do chris you just
signed up for a month and
i don't bench what you want i don't but
i'm too lazy
to turn the things on and off but that's
probably what i should do if i want to
pinch a couple of pennies
yeah um okay now so like the restaurants
during the pandemic
these big chains like amc regal they
have the capital or the ability to get
well to write this out yeah right
not all of them did you know amc did the
right thing they did
a smart thing by raising capital during
that whole gamestop
saga at the end of january when their
stock price just skyrocketed
with the wall street bets and the social
media reddit crowd just piled into their
stock at high prices
so they did the right thing gamestop
didn't at the at that time but amc says
that they've raised enough cash as a
billion dollars
back in january that's enough they say
to carry through at least for the first
half of this year and given this notable
pickup that we're seeing
in moviegoers godzilla versus kong and
more theaters opening up
seats could be filled once again there's
hope that amc did the right thing and
they might survive all of this
i mean it's these little it's the
smaller chains like in california the
arc light cinemas
went under what a shame they were i know
um
i'm not a californian but i know people
who are and
especially movie fans loved loved loved
those theaters and
um they say look if they if these
cinemas can't make it in the movie
making capital of the world what does
that mean
and i don't know what arclight books
were like and maybe this is just an
isolated case
well actually their sunset hollywood
location was one of the most profitable
theaters
in america because arc like is is a
higher end
experience like theater i mean it's not
just hundreds and thousands of people
packed in to watch theaters but
you get the couches and the extra
amenities the better food menu
and the drinks so that was wonderful
actually i think they kind of pioneered
the whole experience as a movie like
going to the movies was a fantastic
high-end experience that you could have
so i thought it was quite a shame that
they shut down because these are
beautiful theaters
and they brought in a different way to
watch films in a very enjoyable way
so i hope somebody comes back and says
okay we'll provide the
comfy couches once again production has
been screwed up
yeah uh for a year and so we had this
we did have the stuff we mentioned in
the bottleneck that's that's been
delayed it's being
released in dribs and drabs in the movie
theaters but um
tv and movies has to get kick production
back in gear now which they are
yeah well yes from what i understand
about 60
i think of hollywood filming is back up
and running compared to say
2019 so 60 levels of 2019
and that means the friends reunions
happening from what i understand i'm
excited about that
maybe we'll get some of the other
exciting content that we've been
promised for so long i'm still waiting
for stranger things to be honest that's
my favorite netflix series and it only
by the way i only caught up to it
because of codepen
and there was nothing else to do last
year well i think a lot of people did
that stuff now
susan i learned something else preparing
for this oh yeah we assume that the
price of movie tickets is oh my god it's
through the roof
yes adjusting for inflation i look back
it's been remarkably
stable since just after world war ii
it's been it's
it's gone up and down a dollar here and
there and it's gone it has gone up on it
a little bit the last couple of pandemic
years but for decades it was pretty much
the same in terms of uh in terms of
inflation i don't know about concessions
and that's how the movie theaters
make their money really the popcorn yeah
sure
uh but so there you go it um if you're
going to complain about
the price of movies go back to 1946 get
a job and you'll have the exact same
complaint
now this was inflation-adjusted right so
okay
so you're saying that the the price of a
movie ticket these days is pretty much
the same
as it was in 1940 adjusted for inflation
yep well here both okay because we saw
the worst
box office take almost in history last
year if you
want to adjust it for inflation right i
think the only made how much did they
make last year was only like a
8 billion or something like that i mean
that was a that was a hard hard year for
the movie industry
and also people that work in the filming
industry as well since production was
shut down
pretty much across the board but i would
say that amc cinemark these movie
theater chains
they want their money back and in order
to please shareholders
they better see a resurgence in ticket
sales
uh oscars are sunday do you care did you
see a lot of them do you see any of them
you have a
favorite you have a favorite i do have a
favorite tell me what you thought if you
watched nomad land
it was all right i saw four i saw four
of the nominees for the nominees okay
and i know mad land and um
uh judas and the black messiah were
probably my two i haven't watched that
one yet
i heard that's really good so i i
watched nomad land
i've watched um the sound of metal which
i thought was a little slow
i mean ris ahmed was very compelling but
still
to get through that was a two and a half
hour film and i thought a lot of this
could have been done in 90.
no man land though was so beautiful it
was aching to watch
because you think about all these
disillusioned older workers
in the economy that have just been left
behind you know having to live in their
cars and their vans
and francis mcdormand my god what a
performance
what did you think it was just so raw
and real it was great it was a terrific
movie and
um like everybody else we saw it we
watched that one on hulu that's right
and
so all of these best picture nominees
very few people if anybody actually saw
it with a crowd
at the movies yeah well that's a good
question i
i think very few and especially with
these artistic films
they're usually small crowds small
theaters anyways not a lot of screens
that show them but yeah it's also a
streaming
a streaming year if you think about it i
think netflix led the way
with nominations once again and apple tv
plus had their first nomination
this year with greyhound and tom hanks
but i'm rooting for chloe zhao you know
i like the diversity as well
in the academy awards something that
they've been promoting since 2016
remember that
that year when they said oscar so white
was a hashtag but this year
you're looking at a lot more diversity
which i appreciate
so the bozeman in the best actor
category likely a winner right
yeah and i think you're and i think she
will yes suppose and i think she will
actually win for directing nomad land i
wouldn't
well i wouldn't be surprised anyway it
was so beautifully shot i mean those sun
the sunsets were gorgeous against the
backdrop of the mountains i thought it
was just spectacular
well i haven't been to the movies in
more than a year i plan to get out there
as soon as possible now that i've got
the uh
the jabs yeah so uh paying
15 and then you'll buy the popcorn and
the pop on top
maybe some some chewies i feel like it's
my duty i've got a little
independent theater within walking
distance from me that i never sneak any
food into because i know that's how the
guy makes his money and i buy the
biggest popcorn
i try my best thank you for coming on uh
susan lee with fox business on the fox
news rundown susan thank you
thank you
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
the hand-drawn sign said dylan's food
drive
it was a poster that was taped to two
pvc pipes that were stuck inside
construction cones to support them
as the associated press reports the
setup seen by neighbors on their morning
stroll as well as drivers who slowed
down
was a familiar sight eight-year-old
dylan pfeiffer has been doing food
drives from his home in metro phoenix in
response to the pandemic
he told the ap that it started when he
transitioned into virtual learning with
his school
he'd heard on the news that some
students across the country were having
a hard time with remote learning
because they didn't have internet
service so he wanted to quote give
internet to people he says he and his
mom decided it was going to be difficult
to do that
but that doing food drives to feed
people who needed it
that was something within reach so dylan
spends hours
drawing posters going door to door to
hand out flyers and working with his mom
to post the information to facebook
so far he's hosted three food drives
from his home
and is planning the next one for june
when summer vacation starts
dylan says he's collected more than a
thousand cans and boxes of
non-perishable food and more than nine
hundred dollars in donations
on its website st mary's food bank in
phoenix says it can convert a dollar
into seven meals meaning dylan has been
able to provide
more than 6 500 meals on just monetary
donations
dylan says he'd do a food drive every
day if he could he doesn't just collect
the food
he and his younger sister have even
attended a couple of food packing events
at the facility where the community
donations are sorted and packed for
residents and families in need
and dylan has a message for others quote
i would tell other kids who wanted to
host
food drives to just do it tanya j powers
fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
mark t said mark
what's on your mind the guilty verdicts
in the derek chovin trial gave president
biden a once
in a presidency opportunity to deliver
on his promise of unity and
bipartisanship
to seize it he should immediately call
senator tim scott
and offer to work with him to pass
bipartisan police reform legislation
after the murder of george floyd last
spring senator scott wanted to bring
republicans and democrats together to
get something done on police reform
as a black man who had experienced
police discrimination he did not want to
let the moment pass
without bipartisan action so he
introduced the justice act
and incorporated a number of democratic
proposals into his legislation
these include making lynching a federal
hate crime and withholding funds to
police departments that fail to report
to the justice department
when no knock warrants are used scott's
bill could have been the basis for
bipartisan compromise
but five months away from a presidential
election democrats were not interested
in bipartisanship
rather than work with scott democratic
leaders attacked him
senator richard durbin the second
ranking democrat in the senate called
scott's bill a quote
token half-hearted approach durbin later
apologized for using the word token
after scott said it hurts my soul
house speaker nancy pelosi said scott's
bill was quote trying to get away with
murder actually
the murder of george floyd unquote
despite these shameful personal attacks
scott still tried to reach across the
aisle at his urging then senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell offered to allow
unlimited amendments
and scott promised to help filibuster
his own bill if democrats did not get
the votes they saw
he even told his democratic colleagues
he would vote to support some of their
amendments to improve the bill
such as expanding the definition of
chokeholds and collecting data not just
on serious bodily injury and death
but on all use of force by police with
scott on board
many of those democratic amendments
would have gotten enough republican
support to pass
and if the final result was still not
satisfactory democrats would have had
another chance to improve the bill
further in negotiations with the house
but instead of taking scott's
outstretched hand senate democrats voted
to filibuster his bill
using the very tool they now dismiss as
a jim crow relic
to stop a black senator from moving
forward on police report
12 senators would have been enough to
overcome a filibuster but in the end
only three members of the democratic
caucus senators angus king joe manchin
and doug jones
voted to advance scott's bill which
killed any chance of passing police
reform
now the chauvin verdict has created an
opportunity for biden to change that
during the campaign biden pledged that
as president he would quote work across
the aisle to reach consensus unquote
well here's his chance justice president
george w bush reached out to senator ted
kennedy
to pass bipartisan education reform
biden should reach out to scott and work
with him on bipartisan police reform
he should insist that senate democrats
bring the bill he negotiates with scott
not a democratic substitute to the floor
and pass it with a filibuster-proof
bipartisan majority
he should call on house democrats to
support the compromise he reaches with
scott
and he should invite scott and other
republicans to the white house so he can
sign the bill into law surrounded by
leaders of both parties
after his election biden declared quote
the refusal of democrats and republicans
to cooperate with each other is not some
mysterious force beyond our control it's
a decision a choice we make
unquote if biden makes a choice not to
cooperate at this moment
on this issue then his inaugural promise
to put his whole soul
into uniting the country was nothing
more than a lie
i'm mark thiessen
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
[Music]
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day
with some of the biggest newsmakers and
guests listen live on the fox news app
or get the free podcast at
guybensonshow.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes